Nghe có tối đầu tiên mình ngùa trong những kẻ khuồ trọt
Thế này là rất mình vào trong kẻ lọt
Hồi đầu lạnh mình
Bấm giợt với trong lấy kẻ kết truyến những bà vệ m intoo là
Thế mếc mình còn ngọt có phố
Mà mình có thích chui và đảy
Không có bự án năm em khi không có vết gì là phối
Đối là điều một câu bẹ mười lần tới
Họt được ghi lên thành mùa sình và gái lần dày
Chờ đẫn một ngày
Bất người la thế cho cầu một chiến bán
Anh nghĩ là một người úc, mấy chiều, một câu là em có hoặc tiền anh thì đến quá kia sê ở kia
mà để chính là cái quyết định mình ý là nó thay đồ tỏa mụ ở đơ của mình
Từng không giám tình bất kỳ ai, duy vì là chất hạm người phải đi khí hành ngạn đứa trẻ được phố tin vòng mình
Tại sao?
Anh không gạo em sơ hợp hợp, hồi câu đòi này nó làm cho mình, bừng quý
và những người nghĩ của đình là hả, nên như không phải là mình, tiền lại
Hết mời của chúng tôi không này, đối vui, CEO của Blue Dragon,
nó chức phi trị phố giúp đặt các trẻ em lại thành, quý vị đặt quay trở lại với the first step
Nó first step là nơi chúng tôi sẽ trọng chuyện với những người dẫn giật hơn
Lăng nghe lý cho họ hợi tạo và cách họ trữ thật